i gotten the chance to interact with uh
uh this is matthew johnson from johns
hopkins he's doing this large-scale
study of psychedelics
it's it's becoming more and more i've
gotten a chance to interact with that
community of scientists working on
psychedelics
but because of that that opened the door
to me to
all these uh what are they called
psychonauts the people who
like you said the 10 who like i don't
care i don't know if there's a science
behind this i'm taking the spaceship to
if i'm being the first on mars i'll be
uh the
you know you know psychedelic's
interesting in the sense that
in another dimension uh like you said
it's a way to explore the
the limits of the human mind like what
is this thing capable of doing
because you kind of like when you dream
you detach it i don't know exactly in
your science of it but
you detach your like reality
from what your mind the images your mind
is able to conjure up and your mind goes
into weird
places and like entities appear somehow
freudian type of like trauma is probably
connected in there somehow but you start
to have like these
weird vivid worlds that like so do you
actively dream
do you why not i have like six
six hours of dreams and i it's like
really useful time
i know i do i haven't uh i don't for
some reason i just knock out
and uh i have sometimes like anxiety
inducing kind of like
very pragmatic like nightmare type of
dreams
but not nothing fun nothing nothing fun
nothing fun
i i try i unfortunately have mostly have
fun
in uh the waking world which is very
limited in the amount of fun you can
have
it's not that limited either yeah that's
what we'll have to talk
yeah i need instructions uh yeah there's
like a manual for that
you might want to i looked it up
i'll ask elon what uh what did you dream
you know years ago and i i read about
you know
like you know a book about how to have
you know
become aware of your dreams i i worked
on it for a while like there's this
trick about
you know imagine you can see your hands
and look out and
and i got somewhat good at it like but
my mostly
when i'm thinking about things or
working on problems i i
i prep myself before i go to sleep it's
like i
i pull into my mind all the things i
want to work on or think about
and then that let's say greatly improves
the chances that i'll i'll work on that
while i'm sleeping
and then and then i also you know
basically asked to remember it
and i often remember very detailed
within the dream
yeah or outside the dream well to bring
it up in in my dreaming and then to
remember it when i wake up
it's just it's more of a meditative
practice you say
you know prepare yourself to do that
like if you go to you know the sleep
still gnashing your teeth about some
random thing that happened
that you're not that really interested
in you'll dream about it
that's really interesting maybe but but
you can direct your dreams
somewhat by prepping you know i'm gonna
have to try that it's really interesting
like the most important the interesting
not like uh
what what did this guy send an email
kind of like stupid worry stuff but like
fundamental problems you're actually
concerned about yeah
prepping and interesting things you're
worried about or books you're reading or
you know some great conversation you had
or something
some adventure you want to have like
there's there's a lot of
space there and
and it seems to work that
you know my percentage of interesting
dreams and memories went up
you